Một tháng 11, nhá trách nhiên đồ đi siê thông báo, vẫn còn những nhất chỉ có thập xin bị mắt cạnh,
trong vụ sập nhà cộng quyện tại trường lội chú hồi giao ăn khô chíni,
ở thị tránh xí đôi cho tình đón chává, bầu biệt sảy ra kia hàng chá mọc xin đang làm lễ cộng quyện,
khiến nhiều em không kiếp thật hơn, đến nay, những bán người tự thiệt mặt và khoảng 1 chăm mê bị thương,
nhiều trường hợp bị thương năng.
Hơn bà trình như bình thương hộ đang hình trường chín khai, nhưng gặp như hoa khăn,
gió kết cầu biệt tông lần mắt ở định, các lực lượng lợi trọng đạo thuộc công để tránh quyết cơ xập hem,
đồng thời bà mô xí nước và thử phòng qua khai hẹp cho những người còn đáng mắt kẹp.
Bì phát hiện giống hiệu sự sống mang lại hi vào, sống củ chữa thấy của chiến sành dật thời gian để cảm giao.
Hùa sức trường hợp đã sống nếu một chung cạnh báo, vây tình trạng xuống các của các sợ hạ tình giống sộp tại nhiều khu vực ở INU di,
nơi học sinh và đối sịn với nhiều dùi sò vẻa tròn.
Chúng khi đó, tại Philipein chính quyền đang sống tòa lực trực công tát tình kiếm và cường nạn,
sông trên đồng đất mạnh só phía chiến đồ, sảy ra tối này bà mềm thịt chiến tại phía bác đạo xíu.
Cơ quan phòng vệ dân sự cho biết, sống người thìm mang đã tăng lên sống người chiến hợi với một trong bố mấy bảy người bị thương,
và ý nhất an hai toàn nhà hữu hải nghiêm trọng.
Hơn sống trong dư trình thích tục làm dung chuyển khu vực.
Đà ra thích tức lớn chứ việc báo đảm anh toàn các công trình, đặc biệt là chương học.